every milestone in my life I just
was ambitious to get to the next one
without thinking about the bigger plan
of starting a startup this was a kind of
a dream for me now I'm trying to fill
this Gap by getting back to kirat
modskin where I grew and talking to
Young students their high school and
filling this Gap by by getting them to
know someone from this world for them to
be able to reach out and say hey this is
my dream tell me what I need to do in
order to to make it welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctec
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
excited to go underground together it
was your company sodigo and and sort of
understanding how you're leveraging a
deep technology to to map underground in
in new ways and and why do we even need
to do that and what's our motivation to
do that and so it's going to be a really
fun episode for the both of us I hope
and I'm excited to dive into your world
so again thank you very much for being
here and tell me a little bit about
yourself and how you found yourself
working on underground mapping
yeah
and then so where should I start I go
with the coyote it's a North Israel then
they finished the technion did the
software engineering and Masters in
computer science and enlisted in the
Army and did some Service uh some
service seven years in eight one and
8200 and led r d teams
um a multiple r d teams uh complex
projects that required a heavy investing
on resources on software resources to
get to the end line
um and then of course throughout this
journey it was a decade of Journey I met
Jeremy and you give a who are my
co-founders and them colleagues and
Friends another like it's a it's a life
Journey so they they're well all the
time with me and we decided around
ten years ago I think may have given
myself to start a company it was only at
the the
um I don't know ideation or even it
wasn't a concourse thing but we started
to have some meetings
um I don't want to say meetings back
then 10 years ago but it was like a a
monthly meeting where we talk about it
and we think about it how would it look
like and such and then when he was it
was with me in the sagot which is a
academic
um military service before enlisting in
the Army
um well you do academic studies a
certain field I did the computer science
before a listing and we met there in
this program
and when we enlisted 281
an intelligence unit we met Jeremy uh
around seven years ago well seven years
ago when we released from the Army but
it's already nine years ago
um and we met him and we knew right away
that we're going to do something
together
uh so we started some kind of bi-weekly
meetings around these topics and the
thinking about different ideas which
were absolutely useless back then you
know like thinking about it
retrospecting about it you see how
useless it was but it was mentally
preparing you to take this leap of faith
and do it and once we left the Army in
2021 January 2021 and this is a when our
journey started it's in a garage at the
garage where we did some ideation for
six months
what what did you realize you were going
into and what surprised you now so if
you're looking back because obviously
you were you know you're very
intentional about the process that you
were doing to start this company and and
the the process but but now looking back
how do you describe what you were
thinking or what you were aware of in
terms of how it's going to be versus
what it actually was
to tell you the truth I didn't really
know that much back then about what's
going to be ahead of me uh I wasn't
aware of the risks of the sacrifice that
you need to make in order to jump and to
take this
this jump into this world
for me personally I don't want to talk
about my co-founders because they had
their own Journey but every milestone in
my life I just
was ambitious to get to the next one
without thinking about the the a bigger
plan of uh
starting a startup
it sounds but he just wanted like kids
playing like I want to start a startup
but this was a kind of a dream for me uh
going where I grew up growing where I
grew
um and now I'm trying to fill this Gap
by getting back to kirat modskin where I
grew and the talking to Young students
at their high school and filling this
Gap by by getting them to know someone
from this world for them to be able to
reach out and say hey this is my dream
tell me what I need to do in order to to
make it when I'm 30 and I want to open
my startup and I think and I truly
believe that this journey starts it like
being in high school and taking the
right decisions so
I love it okay so let's talk about
underground mapping and what this whole
thing is about I want what I really want
to know you do I want to know why this
is the coolest thing anybody has ever
worked on that's what I want to know
yeah
uh so basically what we do in Exotica is
that we try and we succeed obviously
yeah oh oh we try to succeed it's it's
Pilots over Pilots over Pilots where we
need to demonstrate it with that we are
able to do it but we try to understand
what's going on on the ground without
penetrating the ground like we're doing
it by moving sensors physical sensors
above the ground in a snake like button
and then of course the
getting all the signals the physical
signals and moving them in turn to the
cloud where we of course execute
deployed algorithms and and different
models on the data in order to get the
underground map in accurate Underground
map and not the not the not the ones the
dangerous color the industry is
currently used
uh why is it the coolest thing that the
one can work in because
um I think that it involves the physical
world like being in the field with the
the cutting-edge technology and the
algorithmic angle a software team needs
to handle massive massive amounts of
data and we're talking about hundreds of
gigs every day of scanning in the field
uh so I think it just involves different
uh
top tier Technologies in order to solve
this problem and it no wonder that no
one truly engaged with this problem in
this integrated way that Exotica does
because it truly involves lots of
professions and we are employing in the
in our company different profession that
we have different employees from
different professions we have mechanical
engineers who have electrical engineers
here software Engineers algorithmic guys
a geophysicist geologists why is this
the most why is this such an important
thing to do why why is it why is it a
problem worth solving
okay great question uh it's it's a
massive problem in the world to
understand what's going on on the ground
and whenever you talk with the
constructo
someone that uh
developer that that in that has any
aspect of uh engaging with the
underground he's talking about a very
big pain in his process a very big risk
that need to be mitigated everyone can
tell you about a story where they hit
the pipe where they had to stop the work
and they wait for the redesign of a
change order in order to continue and
frankly take a look at the the
underground
projects around the world there are they
are delaying all the time
um due to underground the unexpected
risks materialized
it's it's a billions of dollars that are
being
wasted on underground risks every every
year and then it's on the Federated
level that is handled in the US
entity that is supposed to you know you
need to call before you even touch the
ground it's just to make just to
understand what you're going through it
it's it's a law over there and so let's
paint me a picture of what are some
things that exodigo who helps with what
is the actual product that you're doing
and how how is your product helping
solve this pain point that you just
mentioned yeah so so we aim to provide
an inaccurate map before even engaging
with the underground before even
designing how do we do it we get today a
site that need to be surveyed we do our
survey and then we provide the developer
with an accurate map of the of the
underground assets this allows them to
reduce the the amounts of change orders
and redesigns this allows them to plan
ahead and and to stay within his budget
this allows him to reduce the carbon
footprint because this obviously
expedite it's the project delivery
um
this takes the biggest risks which is
the underground in in construction
project or one of the biggest risks and
and mitigates it
okay so so now that we're now that we
understand the sort of the why and and
how your mapping helps mitigate those
challenges let's dive into the
technology you know you're the chief
technology officer and I'd love to start
a little bit what does it mean for you
to be the CTO of this company that's it
what is what is the role for you I I you
know when you look on your
um when you look on your uh on on your
profile online it's it's very evident
that you're taking your role very
seriously and you're very intentional
with what what you're representing in
terms of your role and so I'd love to
sort of capture a little bit of that
essence
sure a we've built our company let's
talk about the lnd segment or the r d
Department in a I don't think it's a
unique way but it's a very scalable way
we have the CTO office which integrates
all the architectural designs and the
guidance and the experience of big
projects and how to handle them as well
as information security and IP
management
and execution of the strategy and we
have the r d which was in charge of
execution
of the different features and the
a product execution this way and the
city I'm the head of the city office and
we have a very talented VP engineer that
was in charge of the lnd and together
we walk in a way that the CTO office
like supports or helps or guide the
teams inside the l d to make a better or
more effective r d process to make more
scalable Solutions uh so this is the
approach that we took here talking about
the different aspects that I did in my
day-to-day is obviously
I I don't think there is a CTO they tell
you that he's not doing it but of course
recording is a big issue and a big chunk
of my day-to-day work
uh forming this relationship with
candidates with top-notch Engineers is
highly important for us in them handling
this person personally what does that
mean so you know as much as you're
willing and feel comfortable what does
that mean to to be very personally
active with it what does that translate
in your eyes yeah
so obviously
when they
I don't know whether it's called it the
sourcing companies or recorded the
addresses your approach you on there on
LinkedIn you don't necessarily answer
but when you when you try to form a
connection a real life connection with
someone with you calling or you you meet
him or it's a an old friend of yours
that you're familiar with this journey
and you and you're approach and you
start having a conversation with him
about any any anything in the world it
means something even in his eyes in your
eyes and then this connection is
sometimes translates to this person
getting to your office and coming just
to see what you're doing and and this is
a way
to fill this gap of the called the world
of recording and that I feel that I I
love doing
um and I'm doing this for the r d in
organization as a whole
yeah okay and then in the in the
day-to-day what is your responsibility
in the day today as CTO of this company
sure so if the day-to-day we're talking
we're walking on the of course with the
help with the lead of Architects we have
a chief software architect and chief
Hardware architect we're working on the
long-term goals of the company we're
working on the architectural designs of
our product of our product and if we're
talking about a multi-sensor car the car
that needs to be able to carry multiple
sensors from different worlds so it
needs to be designed carefully in order
for it this product to be scalable and
to be
scattered around the world it needs to
be designed properly so we're dealing
with it with that of course we're
personal personally I'm dealing with the
IP management of the company
which is which involves of course
patents and the strategy forming the
strategy of the company
um and the last thing is the Outsourcing
different efforts that are not our core
IP even differentiating between
something that is is your core IP and
not your core IP is is a major thing
that you need to put your attention to
in order to not waste resources inside
resources of the company which are
highly highly expensive in terms of
attention and you want to Outsource them
so this is also being handled through
the CTO office
okay so this is a really important point
I'd love to double down on Outsourcing
the non-core elements or the non-ip
elements yeah why why you know what is
the importance of this and how do you
personally do it because this is
something that I personally am very
conscious of as well so how what what is
the what do you mean behind that
statement sure okay so
as you said we're dealing with the
underground and the the the
purpose of this company is to understand
what's going on on the ground building a
visually
a platforms to visualize the outputs of
our company to the clients or designing
a new circuit board
just for something a secondary to our
product or doing anything that is not
directly related to understanding what's
going on on the ground is not it's not a
mandatory thing to be handled inside the
company and we have a limited resources
of whatever of a software of Hardware of
mechanical engineers of algorithmic guys
so if this can be taken outside and be
solved with just a one-time payment and
energy or any other type of a payment
that you are willing to to make I see it
as a is is taking a a good step for the
company by investing this amount and not
necessarily developing this project
inside and you need to think carefully
on this kind of project because it it
can't be too much entangled with your
internal IP because this will obviously
put some other barriers
got it got it okay and so when you're
looking at now you know this decision
making points are there some set
criterias or some said methodologies
that you do that you would recommend
others or or even just you know sharing
what your your own processes internally
for understanding whether something is
relevant for being outsourced or not in
a very tangible manner oh hey okay
um
I'd say that I'm trying to as I just
told you I'm trying to say what our
company does and what the the goal of
this company is and then I'm saying he
is some is there someone more capable
than us of delivering this product like
uh we're dealing with the other goddess
so if you if we need to inverse the
under the the physical signals the
electromagnetic signals into a some kind
of underground the utility of course no
one is more capable than this company
offending this but if we're talking
about building a a circuit some kind of
a circuit there are very talented
Hardware Engineers outside they can
carry this project out and we can go on
and on and
they think about this kind of project
that can be taken outside of course that
it needs to be kind of a standalone and
need to be usually it needs to be not
urgent not so urgent because if it's
super urgent and you have a python of
project this of these kind of projects
so you you might consider having someone
inside
but if it's a single time project or
there is someone a way more talented the
the new the new employee is doing it
outside with way more experience so you
should consider taking it outside and
allowing you
a highly expensive attention expensive
employee working on your core IP yeah no
that makes that makes sense
yeah no no it really does
um and and I love getting to the core of
the you know and just to add just to it
a small bullet on this I think that it's
the part of the CTO responsibility to
get this mechanisms in place to be able
to Outsource a different kind of work so
and basically what I'm what I'm trying
to do as a CTO is I'm trying to build
this mechanisms to be able to let RND or
to be able to let our company as a whole
uh Outsource different projects in in
mechanisms so in
no mechanism it is a good word in the
mecca mechanisms that already were built
with the help of the city of office like
putting the entire legal a a legal
engagement in place or facilitating and
checking that this service provider is
is a talented one is able to to deliver
so once this one this mechanism is in
place you can start Outsource for this
methodology that the city office has has
presented you with
yeah 100
uh you know I really want to thank you
for spending this time with me and
foreign
for a short but but cool episode I think
it was really remarkable over these 20
minutes is two you really hear from you
how how intentional you are about the
way that you are building this company
about your personal role as CTO not just
from the pain points and the product
perspective and the impact but also how
you're treating the personalities that
you're meeting the candidates that
you're bringing on board and how and the
leadership role that you're taking with
you uh which boils down not only for the
you know hiring process and the company
management but also for making critical
decisions on what should be you know
internal internally built versus
externally outsourced and so I really
want to thank you for this time I
greatly enjoyed it thank you thank you
very much enjoy it too thank you very
much
foreign
[Music]